THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE.
ABOUT OF SECRETARY.
HOW CAN YOU CALL OF CULTURAL
FORWARD WORKER PLEASE?
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU.
DALY HERE FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON THEIR HARPER [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
REFORM.
APPROVAL OF THE CAN.
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR JOINING ME TODAY.
WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE AGENDA
TODAY ITEM.
NUMBER ONE SCR ONE FIFTY NINE SO
CONSENT.
AND WE DO HAVE A FIRST BY MR DO
SECOND BY MISTER GIPSON.
MAN THIRTY PLEASE CULTURAL.
ON THE CAN THANK CALENDAR
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE FONG FONG
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN [inaudible]
CHIU.
DALY DALY AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GIPSON AYE AYE GIPSON AYE
HARPER.
HARPER ON A MATHIS [inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE NAZARIAN.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE. TEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROOM ROLL OPEN FOR A
FEW MINUTES OF FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOUR CHAIR I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CHIU.
CHIU AYE CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN TO
SARAH
.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE FINAL VOTE.
TWELVE TO ZERO LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS NOW
COMPLETE THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED